[Applause]
behold the first impeachment ever based
on imagination first look at this sad
bunch it's like it's like the Last
Supper at the counter at Wendy's when
they could find no crime they steal the
plot of Minority Report
let's stop Trump from doing stuff he
hasn't done yet
because they have the stuff they had on
him was garbage the dossier
I wonder if Kellyanne knows what it
means it's a good time to remind
everybody dossier is just a fancy French
term for a load of crap gotta love her
so the media gobbled up this fever dream
based on drunken gossip a sex fantasy
designed to get Michael more horny
remember remember Putin hired hookers to
defile a bed where the Obamas once slept
all in the presence of evil Donald Trump
all that was missing was a sex toy
shaped like Mike Huckabee's bass guitar
yeah still the media bought it because
they wanted to it's a dilemma for me the
meeting the dams they're like a person
you know who's making a disastrous
decision like marrying Charlie Sheen you
want to say no no no no no don't do that
but you realize this person has screwed
all of us since day one so instead you
say median Democrats you go for it right
Adam
[Applause]
you mean like today in life I don't know
I don't keep track irresponsible have
you cheated on your taxes no
apple-picking
if you were an apple I wouldn't pick you
next you know I've never dated a
congressman before and you never will
Negus what kind of music do you like
balloons I like to blow them up in my
basement slowly let the air out okay
well I like the older stuff like the
Beatles never heard of them would you
like to hear my favorite song
sure
[Applause]
next 17 errors were made in the Pfizer
process yet we're told there was no bias
but if the errors all went in one
direction how's that unintentional I
mean maybe I didn't mean to rob that
bank
but the 17 mistakes I made along the way
you know slipping and falling into that
ski mask with my hand accidentally
landing on that gun and then stumbling
blindly into the savings and loan if I
pure chance scribbling give me the money
or you're gonna die on the back of a
deposit slip what are the odds of me
making all those mistakes like that in a
row which is why no one buys this crap
as the impeachment satisfies a craven
media it keeps helping Trump in key
battleground states what does that
remind you of the last election remember
it was the media who devoted hours to
bashing Trump the result he won and yet
the media is doing it again with
impeachment mocking Trump at his
defenders while pretending this isn't
some sham and Trump's numbers just go up
it's like the Tory landslide in England
a rebuke of rabid leftism if our Dems
were smart they'd take that as a preview
of what could happen here you know it's
like watching your buddy take the drug
first
but our dams aren't that smart and the
media protects their stupidity from its
consequences not to let the Republicans
off the hook however they all should
have walked out of that hearing but by
staying they gave the charade some
credence and a charade it was one
Democrat even admits the impeachment
vote was delayed because it was too late
for a TV audience so how delusional do
you have to be to think the solution for
your idiotic farce is to get more people
to see your idiotic farce right Adam and
now Adam Schiff conducts his daily
meditation so stressed need to relax
Adam
[Music]
such a sweet symphony of sound it's
getting weirder and weirder what does it
tell you when the establishment media
and establishment politicians are all
trying to do the same thing they sense
the establishments under attack and it
is who'da thought though that the most
radical figure in modern history is a
reality TV star with orange hair why not
let him explain it I'm the only
politician of the history that I've
actually kept more promises than I made
[Applause]
we need to hear that again I'm the only
politician of the history that I've
actually kept more promises than I made
that makes absolutely no sense but it's
brilliant
I mean it's true how did he make that
true that was that possible so the more
the critics attack him the more they
prove him right Andrew Breitbart once
said politics is downstream from culture
so this massive irrational reaction to
trump isn't political at all but
cultural for once the media academia
entertainment complex feels threatened
an impeachment is how the emotionally
damaged fight back but it's like the
Harlem Globetrotters every game you know
how it's gonna unfold
you know the outcome so we watch Pelosi
following the other clowns off a cliff
engaging in an actual abuse of power
with Democrats vowing that they'll keep
impeaching till the very end it's like
that tired cliché about proof of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over again despite getting the same bad
result we have a better definition it's
called listening to Adam Schiff and now
Adam Schiff tries out his new Amazon
Alexa hey boss Merry Christmas I got an
Alexa no thank you I'm allergic to
chocolate
no no it's a it's a digital assistant
you can ask it anything no no that's not
a magic 8-ball you just talk to it
I'd like to order a pizza no okay yeah
just put it on the desk and speak Alexa
please fetch me some milk I'm sorry I
can't help with you excuse me fetch me
some hot milk spare what the heck is
wrong with you
[Laughter]
it burns but I like it